Guten Morgen Lino. Guten Morgen Tim.
Guten Morgen Linus. Wer wer wird denn Weltmeister?
Im Eishockey? Keine Ahnung.
Lockbuch, Netzpolitik, euer Kompendium zu allen Fragen, zu Fußball, äh internationalen Sportverstrickungen, global kulturellen Fragestellungen,
Und war noch was anderes? Ach ja, Überwachung, genau. Und Überwachung. Ja, davon gibt's immer noch genug. Kein Mangel,
kein Mangel an Themen, aber so ein bisschen ich befürchte wir werden heute auch wieder so ein bisschen repetitiv. Vielleicht sollten wir mal unser Portfolio erweitern.
Wir werden nicht über Fußball reden. Nee, ich weiß es, du hast jetzt lange darauf hingearbeitet, aber nein.
Nee, da wollte ich auch gar nicht drauf hinaus, aber vielleicht kann man ja einfach generell das Spektrum ein bisschen erweitern, um so bestimmte kulturelle Aspekte,
Weiß ich nicht.
Wie zum Beispiel.
Keine Ahnung. Vorschläge werden entgegengenommen. Aber wir warnen euch gleich vor, irgendwie, wir sind äh stark monothematisch dieses Mal.
Das sagst du, ich.
Ja, also natürlich gegebener Varianten reichen Vielfalt und wir schaffen ja auch aus dem langweiligsten Thema noch was Lustiges rauszuholen. Ja, aber Snowden, Snowden, Snoten.
Ich würde gerne am Anfang dieser Sendung noch kurz äh dem Roland Moritz danken,
und vor allem dem Christian Hönig, die wissen beide genau wieso, denn ich bin ja viele tausend Kilometer gereist, um feine Dinge auf meinem Schreibtisch zu finden,
und äh ja, vielen Dank.
Ja gut, das war's.
Ja, können wir eigentlich jetzt wieder tschüss. Ja, machen wir mal Anstoß hier.
Auf den Platz gehen, meinst du? Ja. Genau. Ja, machen wir mal Anstoß hier. Ja, Snowden äh hat gesagt, er will sich nicht einwechseln lassen.
Genau, ist noch ein Snowden auf der Bank.
Ja, soll, soll eigentlich ins Spiel kommen so? Zumindest fordert äh die eine Mannschaft das, aber Trainer Kalek. Trainer sagt.
Aber Trainer Kalek hat jetzt nochmal dem NSA Untersuchungsausschuss gesagt ähm nee, also wir erinnern uns ja an die schöne Situation, ist ja sowieso kürzlich im NSA untersuchungsausschuss. Jetzt übrigens gerade auch tagt.
In dieser. Mhm.
Ähm.
Opposition will ja Snowden gerne in Deutschland haben zu einer umfassenden Zeugenaussage im NSA Untersuchungsausschuss. Am besten ausgestattet mit einem schönen Asyl, damit auch direkt bei uns bleiben kann,
und äh die Regierungsfraktion ähm,
lehnt sowohl ein Aufenthalts äh als auch jegliche Sicherheitsgarantien für ihn ab,
Trotzdem hatte der NSA Untersuchungsausschuss ja schon vor einiger, vor einigen Wochen entschieden, wir werden snowden am dritten Juli ähm vernehmen,
offen gelassen haben sie allerdings wo oder wie sie das machen möchten,
Und jetzt hatte sich der äh gute Patrick Sensburg ähm mit dem Wunsch nach einem informellen persönlichen Gespräch in Moskau an äh Snowden gewandt beziehungsweise an seinen Rechtsanwalt Karlek,
und der hat dann irgendwie relativ freundlich und bestimmt zurückgeschrieben. Äh das ist ja nun mal wirklich keinen Ausblick gibt, wie man sich hier irgendwie näher kommt. Äh und das für ein Gespräch in Moskau derzeit weder Raum,
noch Bedarf besteht, vor allem, wenn es sich um ein informelles äh handeln soll. Er wies aber, und das fand ich sehr, äh, sehr wichtig, nochmal darauf hin, ähm,
Das Norden, wenn er bisher irgendwo was äh gesagt hat, zum Beispiel im Liebeausschuss des Europaparlamentes, als Sachverständiger vernommen wurde.
Und der NSA Untersuchungsausschuss sich aber nun entschieden hat, ihn als Zeugen zu vernehmen. Und äh da schreibt äh der Anwalt dazu, die Verfahrensrolle und die von,
vom vom Ausschuss erbetene Zeugenaussage würde sich qualitativ und quantitativ gravierend von sämtlichen bisherigen Stellungen nahmen von Herrn Snowden unterscheiden.
Und man ist weiterhin gerne bereit zur Klärung sämtlicher praktischer Fragen einer Zeugenvernehmung im Schriftwege beizutragen.
Was heißt das? Also würde man ihn als Zeugen befragen, würde er Dinge sagen können, dir auch gerne sagen wollen würde, wenn die Rahmenbedingungen stimmen oder heißt das, dass er das ungern tun würde?
Ich denke, dass er äh dass er äh das tun würde, ob nun gerne oder nicht, aber unter den jetzigen Bedingungen eben nicht gerne.
Sagt, wir lassen dich in Moskau verhungern, ist uns doch scheißegal, wie es dir geht. Äh wir wollen nur für uns etwas davon haben. Wir sind aber nicht bereit, dir irgendetwas dafür zu bieten,
Ja, also diesen, dass sie dem überhaupt noch antworten, ja, also ich meine, der wir erinnern uns, der hat sich ja irgendwie öffentlich in die Medien gestellt und gesagt, der
dass er an der Glaubwürdigkeit von zweifelt, ja, dass
ist der ja und der schreibt jetzt dahin, will mich mal informell mit dir unterhalten, weil ich dir ja schon gesagt habe, dass äh dass wir äh dir keinerlei äh Gegenleistungen anbieten,
ähm für dafür, dass du als Zeuge äh Aussagen sollst in unserem Ausschuss, also absolut unver.
Um nochmal die Namen gleich äh klarzumachen, also du redest von Patrick, äh Sensburg, das ist jetzt der aktuelle Vorsitzende äh des NSA Untersuchungsausschusses, nachdem der erste Jahr schon äh gleich Frankfurt äh begangen hat nach kurzer Zeit,
und vielleicht auch nochmal ein Wort zu der zweiten Personalie, die du so äh angesprochen hast. Dirk Kalik,
Wolfgang Harlek, genau, ist Rechtsanwalt, vertritt Snowden,
und ist äh im Übrigen auch ähm ein Rechtsanwalt so aus der Riege des republikanischen Anwältinnen und Anwältevereins. Der,
Sicherlich manchen viel sagt, weil das an sich ein sehr renommierter äh Verein ist, die sich ähm,
auch immer einen Namen gemacht haben, in dem sie so auf Demos äh mitgegangen sind, hier so G acht äh Demos et cetera vor Ort
dann gleich Rechtshilfe äh gewährt haben, et cetera, also nicht nur so jetzt irgendwelche Schnarchnasen, sondern so die äh Rechtsanwälte, die sich auch so aktiv und auch vor Ort
für die Wahrung von Rechten, von Demonstrantinnen eingesetzt haben,
Ich äh hole ein bisschen aus, um gleich ein bisschen Werbung zu machen für einen alten Podcast von mir, weil ich habe mich nämlich immer mit einem Vertreter äh vom RAV äh unterhalten,
für die Gesellschafter, wen das interessiert, äh die Arbeit äh des RAV nochmal ein bisschen äh beleuchtet zu bekommen, der sei darauf verwiesen, aber jetzt halte ich auch schon den Mund.
Gilt als insbesondere als,
Experte für für Menschenrechte hat sich früher äh als das noch eine größere Rolle spielte
viel mit Wehr- und Kriegsdienst Verweigerungsrechten auseinandergesetzt und hat benennt europäisches und internationales Strafrecht sowie Menschenrechte als seine,
Tätigkeitsschwerpunkte. Also das ist mein, wenn du halt AdWords Norden bist, dann gehst kannst du halt nicht zum Anwalt an der nächsten Ecke gehen. Da brauchst du halt jemanden
der äh eine gewisse Expertise in einem Bereich hat, in dem sehr selten äh Verfahren stattfinden. Ähm,
und das ist also der Wolfgang Karlek, der, glaube ich, ein wirklich absolut tadellosen Loymond hat, wo auch immer man sich nach ihm erkundigt,
hört nur sehr Gutes über ihn.
Ja, also kein Snowden für den Untersuchungsausschuss, zumindest nicht unter diesen Bedingungen, finde ich jetzt mal interessant, dass er da eben auch sich nicht länger hinhalten lassen, sondern dass die sich auch mal dazu
bewegt, also dazu geäußert haben, was ihnen quasi bisher so vorgeworfen oder angeboten oder nicht angeboten wurde und gesagt haben so, ja,
so nicht, ja, dann dann halt nicht.
Ja, ist also,
Man muss halt auch einfach mal benennen, woran es da gerade scheitert, ja? Und äh dieses dieses Theater einfach mal nicht mehr weiter mitmachen. Das ist natürlich oder ich hoffe natürlich, dass das ein,
taktischer Zug ist, der den Druck eben auch auf die,
Bundesregierung hier erhöht andererseits hat sich die Bundesregierung ja als ausgesprochen druckresistent bisher gezeigt was diese Angelegenheit angeht.
Auf jeden Fall. Das wird auch sicherlich äh noch so bleiben
sollte es nicht irgendwelche weiteren Momente geben, wo ich jetzt nicht in der Lage mich sehe, ein gutes Beispiel zu benennen. Das sind so die Arten von Nachrichten, mit denen man dann auch irgendwie nicht gerechnet hat.
Also meinst du zum Beispiel, wenn jetzt irgendwie der Bundestag sein Internet von Horizon beziehen würde?
Na ja, ich meine, so was würde der Bundestag ja nicht tun, weil äh dann käme ja das Internet direkt äh von den Amerikanern oder zumindest vom Ausland und das oder?
Ja, es, also,
Haben sie rausgefunden, ich weiß gar nicht genau, wer's war. Ich weiß, war das jetzt sogar äh dann Netzpolitik org, über über André, die den Hinweis bekommen und ihm nachgegangen sind. Ähm,
Es war auf jeden Fall kein Geheimnis, denn äh jeder Mensch kann,
kennen, dass ein Teil des Bundestags eben aus dem autonomen System siebenhundertzwei kommt, was äh MCI zugeordnet ist und MCI wurde vor weiß ich nicht wie viel Jahren von Horizon gekauft. Das heißt, ein größerer Teil
äh Bundestagsinternet Traffics geht direkt,
durch. Ich habe gestern nochmal kurz geschaut, deren ähm Nail-Server haben auch IP-Adressen in dem Range und sie äh akzeptieren auch unverschüsselte Verbindungen,
Das heißt, ähm das kann man eigentlich komfortabler kaum machen.
Herr hat äh sagen wir mal den Bundestag noch nicht so ganz erreicht dann, ne?
Also da wird's natürlich jetzt.
Vielleicht auch eine gute Erklärung, dass der Bundestag im Prinzip so 'ne exterritoriale Zone ist, in der dann halt auch die NSA nicht die Gesetze verletzt, während sie den kompletten Bundestagstreffic.
Ist völlig.
Also sie haben alles, ja? Die haben sozusagen Vollüberwachung und Vorratsdatenspeicherung als einziger, also das Privileg des Abgeordneten äh macht sich auch an solchen Dingen fest.
Aber das ist natürlich ein bisschen auch der der Zwiespalt bei dieser Meldung, ähm der da genau jetzt so dies, also es es ist halt,
Es wird von allen dann auch teilweise äh zurecht kritisiert. Natürlich eine Vorlage für dieses USA-Geschrei.
Und ich versuche ja seit einiger Zeit auch darauf hinzuarbeiten, dass wir uns davon mal langsam verabschieden, ne? Weil wir das Problem ist nicht nur ein,
USA, NSA-Problem,
sondern wie wir auch, da kommen wir gleich zu in dieser Woche gelernt haben, eines, was äh Deutschland ganz im Konkreten betrifft. Insofern ist es natürlich relativ ähm.
Also was Deutschland nicht nur als Opfer betrifft, sagen wir es mal so rum, ja?
Genommen, sondern da als als Mitwisser und Mittäter betrifft. Und aber natürlich ist es trotzdem peinlich, dass man äh,
Dass er so einen Quatsch macht, ja? Also wenn man das hier mit sich so einfügt, wie lange jetzt schon von diesem Schland näht und E-Mail made in Germany die Rede ist, ja, da sieht man dann
Was für ein absoluter Aktionismus da das ist, wenn man seine eigene äh Infrastruktur da noch nicht mal irgendwie annähernd,
auf dem Sicherheitsniveau hebt, von dem man behauptet, dass es sinnvoll wäre, ja, aber es sei natürlich auch der Hinweis gestattet, dass es eigentlich egal sein sollte,
wenn man denn äh seine Kommunikation vernünftig absichern würde. Aber das ist eben beim Bundestag auch nicht der.
Ja und nicht nur beim Bundestag, also es gab hier auch noch den Hinweis, dass äh auch das Abgeordnetenhaus in äh Berlin seine äh Telekommunikationsdienstleistungen an der Stelle von Kolt bezieht. Kolt steht für City auf Landen Telekom, ja. Äh im Übrigen ein sehr verbreiteter äh Beckbon Provider
Nicht nur in Berlin
also europaweit, einer der ganz äh großen Beckbonan-Anbieter, auch so einer von denen, die schon immer im Bankenbereich sehr stark waren, äh also überhaupt,
Großkundengeschäft äh unterwegs waren in dem Sinne überhaupt gar keinen Endkundengeschäft unterhalten.
Also es wird auch die Luft natürlich dünn, wenn du dich da hinstellst und sagst, du hast hier so einen ganzen Bundestag mit wie viel Leute sitzt da? Sechshundert Abgeordnete, jeder drei Mitarbeiter, ähm da kann's ja nicht zur Telekom gehen und sagen einmal, VDSL,
vernünftige Anbindung und da gibt's auch nur noch wenige Anbieter.
Ähm du willst mir noch nicht erzählen, dass die Telekom nicht in der Lage wäre, da eine entsprechende Erschließung vorzunehmen.
Telekom ist sicherlich zu viel in der Lage, aber das ist ja auch genau der der Punkt, den wir bei dem.
Aber nicht zwischen Montag und Freitag jetzt.
Na, die werden,
Hypothese, Vorsicht, aber die äh der der Hintergrund wird wahrscheinlich auch da der Preis sein. Ja, das heißt, genau das, was irgendwie ein sich natürlich ergebende Schlandnett verhindert hat, nämlich, dass die Telekom einfach zu hohe Preise verlangt,
und das deshalb ähm ein Großteil des Traffics lieber den Umweg über die USA geht, wo die äh wo die äh Vereinbarungen.
Die Firma, die mehrheitlich von diesem Staat geöhnt wird. Kann dem Staat selber keine Dienstleistungen bereitstellen, die konkurrenzfähig sind.
Das würde mich nicht wundern, wenn das der Hintergrund ist, aber wie gesagt, das ist eine Hypothese. Also es wäre ja noch schöner, wenn die Telekom das billiger angeboten hätte.
Für den Bundestag? Na, was heißt billiger? Also, wenn sie es zu wettbewerbsfähigen Preisen anbietet, da kann ja jetzt kein Fehler äh drin.
Macht die Telekom doch nicht, die bietet doch nichts zu Wettbewerbsfähigen Preisen an. Das haben wir noch.
Nein, aber das wäre ja jetzt auch kein schlechter Move so mal.
Schlechter Move gewesen.
Ja. Andererseits hätte es vielleicht auch durchaus ein Kriterium sein können, wem irgendwie dieses Unternehmen gehört, mit dem man sich da irgendwie seine Daten nach draußen tragen lässt,
Ich meine, wenn die da irgendwie äh ihr Geld rein und rausfahren, dann bestellen sie ja ihren Wagen auch nicht bei Panzerknacker,
Na ja, gut, aber du hast schon recht. Also diese ganze Sichtweise auf, wer denn nun die Daten transportiert, ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen missleeding, weil's einfach irgendwo am Ende auch Schnurz ist.
Es sollte, es sollte Schnurz sein und ähm.
Wenn man denn sowieso alle mal ordentlich verschlüsseln würde, zum Beispiel seinen E-Mail-Verkehr.
Das Pferd zum Beispiel eine Möglichkeit, ne, aber also,
Es ist halt, es ist eine schöne Peinlichkeit, aber ich würde davor äh oder ich versuche davor zu warnen, dass man da jetzt irgendwie ähm.
Rein liest.
Immer nur sagt, ja die USA, die USA, die USA, weil, wie gesagt, und wir haben's ja jetzt heute gelernt oder in dieser Woche gelernt, ähm dass bereits vor zehn Jahren, das fand ich echt stark,
Bereits vor zehn Jahren hat der BND ausführlich,
NSA zusammengearbeitet und Daten vom DCX direkt äh rübergepumpt zur NSA,
Das war jetzt ein, jetzt wird der Tim nervös, weil ich den Übergang zu fließend gemacht habe.
Ja. Ich bin ja hier für die Qualitätssicherung äh zuständig und äh.
Quality esurens, bitte, QA.
Na ja, ist ist Bienen ist Schuld.
Ja ähm da lernen wir also ein Jahr über ein Jahr nach Beginn dieser gesamten Affäre, dass der
BND am Dezix schon zweitausendvier Daten abgeschnorchelt hat für die NSA und sie ungefiltert oder oder nur grob gefiltert mit der NSA
geteilt hat, ja? Und das alles äh zweitausendvier als Steinmeier, wenn ich mich recht entsinne, äh im Bundes äh Kanzleramt als Kanzleramtsminister saß.
Der Selbe Steinmeier, der da heute noch rumhampelt und irgendwie ein einen erzählt. Zweitausendsieben haben sie dann diese Zusammenarbeit als politisch zu heikel eingestellt,
und anstelle einer Weiterleitung von Rohdaten äh gibt der BND äh seither die Zusammenfassungen, seiner eigenen,
Spionagetätigkeit dann an die NSA weiter. Mit anderen Worten.
Man konnte,
heute oder im vergangenen Jahr zurecht behaupten, dass die NSA kein direkten Zugang auf die Rohdaten hat,
sie hat ihn nur vermittelt durch den BND
der die äh Ergebnisse seiner Auswertung mit der NSA teilt und damit er diese Auswertung vernünftig vornimmt, ähm auf die Arbeits äh Grundlagen und Tools äh der NSA zurückgreift, zum Beispiel auf das Ex-Keescore-System.
Die ganze Zeit über Kanzleramtsminister, ist ja äh der war doch nicht.
Da müsstest du auf seine ähm auf seiner äh Wikipedia Seite mal nachschauen, aber es fällt in diesen Zeitrahm.
Grade. Na ja, also zweitausendvier war er ja noch unter Schröder äh unterwegs. Zweitausendfünf kamen ja dann die große äh Koalition.
Äh Gott, wie schreiben die sich denn immer alle? Das ist ja.
Also ich ich äh beziehe da oder ich,
greife da deshalb äh nenne ich da den Namen Frank-Walter Steinmeier wegen des nächsten Themas, aber ich will's nicht zu glatten Übergang wieder machen, weil du gerade an dem anderen Computer bist. Ähm.
Ja, nee, muss man nur.
Dass da natürlich Menschen, die heute noch in der äh in der Politik eine entscheidende Rolle spielen, damals schon an dieser Angelegenheit beteiligt waren. Ich sage das deshalb, weil es eben zehn Jahre ist ja schon relativ lang. Und wenn man sich jetzt überlegt,
Und das finde ich hier den interessanten Hintergrund. Wenn diese diese Zusammenarbeit zwischen NSA und äh BND in dem Fall,
schon vor zehn Jahren so eng war, dann fügt sich das natürlich auch sehr schön in das Bild, dass die ähm USA ähm einigermaßen irritiert reagieren, wenn die deutsche Bundesregierung da jetzt,
irgendwie ein bisschen zu laut wird. Ja, also dass ein Fragenkatalog, ähm den sie dann in Reaktionen auf Snowdens äh Einlassungen,
an die äh an die USA schicken. Äh unbeantwortet bleibt, weil man sich im Zweifelsfall sagt, Moment mal, die Antworten auf diese Fragen, die haben wir doch selber vereinbart schon vor Jahren,
zu antworten. Da können wir euch ja gar nicht drauf antworten, ohne euch noch mehr in die Tinte zu reiten. Ja?
Nochmal historische Klärung, also zweitausendvier war er noch Kanzleramtsminister unter Schröder. Danach war er Außenminister unter Merkel.
Also das heißt, die Absetzung war dann wiederum nicht seine Sache, also oder die Feststellung, dass es politisch zu heikel war, kann ihnen jetzt nicht unmittelbar zugeschrieben werden.
Nein, viel schlimmer, die, die, die, die Anweisung dieser Angelegenheit
nicht, dass man dann irgendwann nach drei Jahren feststellen will, dass vielleicht politisch ein bisschen heikel, wenn wir hier Daten mit der NSA äh vom größten Internet äh Austauschpunkt in Europa
teilen, aber die Anweisung quasi das, dieses, das diese Maßnahme in Kraft getreten ist, dass sie vorbereitet wurde, das fällt genau in seiner Amtszeit.
Aber das die Six ähm leugnet diesen Fakt nach wie vor, oder? Also gab's da nicht einen äh ein Statement sogar noch nach dieser Meldung, dass dem nicht so gewesen sei.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie danach noch mal dazu Stellung genommen haben. Ich weiß, dass es schon vor äh vor Monaten, als es um den.
Haben sie das immer, da haben sie das immer abgestritten und jetzt äh auch nach dieser Meldung meine ich mich gerade zu erinnern, dass es auch nochmal eine Bekräftigung dessen gegeben,
habe, ohne jetzt gerade einen Link produzieren zu können,
äh falls wir den selber nicht produziert bekommen bis zur Veröffentlichung dieser Sendung, dürft ihr den gerne äh bestätigen oder dementieren. Aber grundsätzlich finde ich das auch schon sehr merkwürdig und ich frage mich natürlich, dürfen die nicht? Ja.
Oder wissen sie einfach nicht? Ich meine, dass sie dort Zugänge für den BND bereitstellen.
Ist, glaube ich, klar. Ja, die existieren. Was darüber geschieht liegt vielleicht nicht in ihrem Ermessen.
Weiß es nicht.
In wessen Ermessen. Du meinst jetzt.
Selber.
Ja, also der Geschäftsführer äh wird hier in der Süddeutschen zitiert, mit wir schließen aus, dass irgendein ausländischer oder inländischer Geheimdienst zwischen zweitausendvier und zweitausendsieben,
Zugang zu dem von uns betriebenen Internetknoten und zugehörigen Glasfasernetzen hatte.
Ja, was genau gar nichts aussagt, weil äh der BND oder diese Definition nicht äh fällt und in dem Moment, wo der BND die Daten erhält und selber diesen Zugang äh schafft zu anderen Diensten, es eben einfach nicht mehr in die,
Aussagebereich.
Also Dezix sagt.
Feld, ne?
Im Prinzip, gut, wir waren damals natürlich auch noch um einiges kleiner.
Ähm.
Ähm ne? Klar, vor zehn Jahren war das äh war das Internet noch kleiner und äh die ganze und natürlich auch der Dezix noch nicht äh in dieser zentralen Rolle, in der er jetzt steht.
Waren Sie auch noch nicht der größte Knoten?
Genau und sie sagen äh letztendlich der geheime Zugriff müsse dann woanders stattgefunden haben, jedenfalls nicht bei uns.
Also woanders. Paar Meter weiter.
Ja, aber das äh genau, ein paar Meter weiter am anderen Ende der der Mauer, in der das Glas äh äh verschwand.
Ciao. Gibt's da noch mehr zu zu sagen?
Ja, ich, also es gibt da wahrscheinlich nicht viel, viel mehr zu zu sagen. Das muss man erstmal sacken lassen. Also ich äh ich.
Ich denke, der der den News Value bei dieser Sache ist, eben dieser diese magische Zahl auch seit zehn Jahren,
ja? Nicht erst seit ein paar oder so äh nicht irgendwie zaghaft mal Daten getauscht, sondern zehn Jahre lang,
absolut verheimlicht, ne? Keine Sau wusste davon, parlamentarisches Kontrollgremium, warum sollte man denen so was erzählen? Haben sie ja nicht nachgefragt.
Vor dem iPhone.
Vor dem ja.
Ich versuche mich gerade mal so ein bisschen in die Lage zu versetzen, was denn damals eigentlich gelaufen ist. Ich meine, zweitausendeins, wann ging der Irak Krieg los?
War das schon zweitausendzwei oder war das noch zweitausendeins? Nee, das muss zweitausendzwei.
Ah nein, das also schon zweitausend.
Ach so, äh jetzt verwechsel ich Irak mit Afghanistan.
Ja ja, sie sind natürlich sofort in Afghanistan äh reingegangen und der Krieg ging dann wiederum zweitausenddrei los,
Also zweitausendeins, zwei, da haben sie gleich auf Afghanistan draufgehalten und dann äh hat sich halt schnell dieser politische Druck da aufgebaut in den.
In der Massenvernichtungswaffen im Iran.
Ja genau und überhaupt und der steckt ja irgendwie auch dahinter und es hat ja irgendwie kein Amerikaner geblickt, was da wirklich abgeht und dann ist er durchmarschiert. So und das war natürlich auch hier eine krasse Auseinandersetzung, muss man auch nochmal klarstellen,
ich denke, dass wir in zunehmendem Maße auch Hörer haben, die das jetzt nicht so live mitbekommen haben damals.
Diese Konfrontation zwischen Schröders, Regierung und Schröder im besonderen und seiner Regierung auf der einen Seite und Joschka Fischer, ja und den USA,
Die war ja, äh wie sagt man so schön, an Presidente, also das das war beispiellos. Also noch nie hat sich eine Bundesdeutsche Regierung so aktiv gegen die gegen den politischen Willen der USA gestellt, zumindest in der Öffentlichkeit,
und äh jedem war klar,
dass dass sie damit die USA extrem erzürnen, ja? Wer da jetzt richtig lag und so vollkommen egal im politischen Geschäft
zählen da ganz andere äh Dinge und wir wissen ja, wie groß die und wir wissen's jetzt noch sehr viel mehr. Wie groß und stark die Verflechtung dieser,
starten,
ist. Ja, man könnte jetzt von Freundschaft sprechen. Man kann auch einfach von gemeinsamen wirtschaftlichen Interessen und gemeinsamen politischen Interessen natürlich auch sprechen.
Und Politik ist immer so ein Tipp. So, ja. Gibst du mir das, gebe ich dir das. Gibst du mir das nicht? Nehme ich dir irgendwas anderes weg?
Permanent Druck auf allen Ebenen äh ausgeübt. Äh wird äh wirtschaftlich irgendwie Druck gemacht, äh um irgendwie politisch irgendwas zu bestrafen. Da wird äh
politisch irgendwas
irgendwo äh Druck gemacht, um wirtschaftlich etwas zu strafen und so weiter. Und ich kann mir einfach sehr gut vorstellen, dass nach diesem Desaster zweitausenddrei, also Desaster im Sinne von,
dass hier quasi viel,
gegenseitiges äh Vertrauen, also so gerechtfertigt das jetzt gewesen sein mag oder nicht. Ja, aber es war einfach klar, dass sie sehr viel.
Sehr viel politisches Feuer äh Holz dort eingesetzt haben. Ja, es brannte lichterloh und da war dann irgendwie so ein Joschka Fischer, der sich da hingestellt hat auf der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz und gesagt hat, so,
Leute, warum warum wollt ihr irgendwie den Irak angreifen? Ich ich verstehe's einfach nicht, ja.
Äh schützen Zehnte, die ich mich so aus internationaler Politik entwickeln kann. Das war einfach ein krasses Statement,
und ähm ich glaube, dass sie danach auch sehr viel Druck hatten, quasi jetzt so wieder liebkind zu spielen. Ja, dass dass sie dann.
Haben sie dann gesagt, okay, danke.
Einfach, ja, das ist jetzt von mir eine sehr äh sehr locker dahergebetete äh These, aber das war, sagen wir mal, die Großwetterlage zweitausendvier,
Wir müssen was gegen den Terror tun,
Deutschland hat nichts getan, ja, der noch nicht mal Sadam gestürzt, was ja so total wichtig, weil das war ja kein, war ja nicht mal rational,
Genau, so und, und, und, und, und äh wahrscheinlich durften sie irgendwie nicht mehr mit am gleichen Tisch essen und um überhaupt einfach mal wieder reingelassen zu werden, im Essensraum und zugucken zu dürfen
dürften sie alle möglichen Forderungen auf den Tisch geknallt bekommen und mit dieser Terrorkeule, die zweitausendvier immer noch vollgezogen hat
denke ich mal, war einfach alles möglich. Dazu mag auch noch dazukommen. Ich versuche das jetzt ein bisschen schön zu reden,
Bundesregierung, ja. Nicht, dass das vertretbare Position werden, aber wenn man mal sich äh reinsetzt, wie groß ist das Verständnis für Internet,
und die Auswirkung dessen, heute, ja? Aus unserer Sicht beklagenswert schlecht. Andererseits im Vergleich zuvor zehn Jahren,
Tag und Nacht. Ich glaube, damals war dem einfach, entweder war ihm das nicht klar oder nicht wichtig,
Ja, das äh lief da so unter Telefon äh Überwachung. Ja hier Datenströme da habt ihr, mach mal.
Das nur ist, dass wir wieder mitspielen dürfen, egal. Und dann drei Jahre später so, hm, hm, vielleicht.
Wir haben jetzt auch Internet.
Ja so irgendjemand hat von unseren Beratern und hat gesagt, das wäre eigentlich nicht so eine geile Idee und stell dir mal vor, da kommt jemand drauf. So ähnlich denke ich mal, könnte das gelaufen sein.
Das kann, das ist eine plausible Theorie.
Mehr kann ich auch nicht bieten. Na ja, aber heutzutage äh werden ja Grundreden gehalten.
Heutzutage werden Grundsatzreden gehalten.
Äh Grundsatzreden, das wollte ich auch sagen.
Aber das ist so eine der das ist jetzt also vorsichtig, ich bin bei diesem Thema nicht besonders informiert, weil ich habe ich habe das Rede-Manuskript von äh Thomas de Maizires Grundsatzrede zum Internet auf der,
Irgendwas mit Datenschutzkonferenz äh versucht zu lesen.
Einschub. Thomas de Maizire, unser Innenminister.
Innenminister, genau. Zu ähm,
eine Grundsatzrede gehalten zum Internet und ich bin jedes Mal irgendwie so mit Augenbluten dann eingeschlafen über dieser Rede. Deswegen kann ich den Inhalt jetzt nicht so gut ähm wiedergeben. Äh,
Also ich habe mal so äh geguckt, ob da irgendwas mit NSA drin vorkommt. Da gibt's also einen Nebensatz, wo drin steht, ja,
Wir haben gesehen, wir Datenschutz ist wichtig, nicht zuletzt durch die NSA,
Also so ungefähr, das war jetzt so Grundsatzrede, Internet, ne, zwanzig Seiten Rede, Manuskript in äh und äh das ist also NSA kommt auch drin vor und er setzt sich irgendwie damit auseinander,
Ja, der Staat müsste natürlich seine Freiheits und Ausgleichsfunktion wahrnehmen,
um sicherzustellen, dass die Nutzung des Netzes und der Zugriff auf das Internet möglichst unbegrenzt bleiben, aber es ist möglichst unbegrenzt, dass immer so ein Wischiwaschi
Das Internet ist ein Raum zur freien Persönlichkeitsentfaltung, genießt damit
besonderen Schutz. Der Staat muss den Zugang sichern. Ähm dann sagt er, wir dürfen nicht die Nutzung darf nicht durch private, weltweit dominierende Großanbieter geregelt werden. Damit könnt ihr natürlich jetzt schon wieder Google meinen,
Ähm und der Staat hat so eine Mitverantwortung für das Internet als Infrastruktur, die für alle zugänglich sein und zuverlässig funktionieren muss. Ja, also,
Das ist also.
Genau, so da also er hat irgendwas gesagt. Sagt er, äh,
schön ist, dass er dann die.
Schutz.
Und am Ende sagte er äh also hier irgendwas mit und ansonsten wollen wir natürlich die IT-Fähigkeiten unserer Geheimdienste,
ausbauen und,
äh äh Fähigkeiten des Bundesamts für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnologie ähm damit wir mehr Hilfe gegen Cyber, Spionage äh bieten können,
also das ist halt so dieser da steht halt nix drin. Da steht nix drin und ist natürlich auch eine wieder eine sehr enttäuschende,
Angelegenheit. Das Schöne war so einen tollen äh Schlusssatz. Ähm,
Der digitale Wandel ist weder gottgegeben, noch teufelswerk. Er ist von Menschen gemacht und darin liegt unsere Chance. Wir können ihn selber gestalten oder sowas. Also,
Das ist äh toll, toll, also super Rede, aber äh und jetzt?
Ja, ich äh könnte mir vorstellen, wenn man äh Thomas de Maizire vor dem Spiel Deutschland USA, was er heute äh stattfindet, nochmal in die Kabine von Klinzmann äh reinschicken. Wer hält die Rede dann einfach nochmal vor den Spielern?
Ist das eine sichere Kiste irgendwie? Die kommen ja auch schon komplett eingeschläfert aufm Platz.
Ich glaube nicht, dass also das ist keine Ahnung. Also es ist es ist eben.
So reden.
Es sind halt so Reden, aber genauer das finde ich auch so fürchterlich. Also diese dass der sich hinsetzt und da irgendwie so eine ja, so eine Rede. Da braucht doch keiner. Da ist ja, ist ja auch nichts drin. Er ist voll,
die arme Luft ist unverschä.
Geatmet wurde.
Dass die Luft nicht wert, die dafür geatmet wurde,
geschweige denn das Papier, auf dem sie.
Ja. Ja gut, ich meine, das frage ich mich bei vielen Reden so. Das ist äh,
meistens nur heiße Luft. Naja gut, sie müssen sich halt irgendwie positionieren und irgendwie da sich immer durch äh mehr ändern, was sie denn jetzt irgendwie für wichtig achten und bloß keinem auf die Füße treten.
Ja und bloß nix sagen, worauf man sie nachher festnageln könnte. Das ist ihm super gelungen. Also da da kann er in der Rede kann er nachher behaupten, alles und nichts mit angekündigt zu.
Ne, aber so ist.
Keiner sagen, du hast aber damals gesagt, das ist das einzige, wir haben gesagt, du hast damals gesagt, der digitale Wandel wäre nicht vom Teufel und jetzt haben wir herausgefunden, ist er nämlich doch das wäre das einzige, der einzige Strick, den man ihm daraus noch drehen könnte.
Ja. Nee, aber da ist er auch ganz vorsichtig. Ist weder A nach B, es ist irgendwie irgendwie AB, aber so genau kann man das jetzt auch wieder nicht sagen. Ja, hm.
Ja, also ganz fürchterlich.
Das US-Repräsentantenhaus hingegen,
hat versucht, etwas Konkretes zu tun. Ähm denn sie hat mit großer Mehrheit dafür gestimmt,
äh die Nutzung von äh technischen Hintertüren durch die NSA einzuschränken,
Und zwar wollen sie der NSA im Prinzip das Budget wegnehmen auf dem Schwarzmarkt für äh das Wissen über IT-Sicherheitslücken shoppen zu gehen.
Also Zero D Explods, wie man so schön sagt, zu kaufen. Mhm.
Also das für, wir haben da ja schon in mehreren Folgen drüber gesprochen, die äh Idee, wenn ich als ähm Sicherheitsforscher,
eine äh Sicherheitslücke finde ist, dass ich entweder an den,
Hersteller der Software oder an die Open Source Community, die diese Software eine vertrauliche Meldung machen kann und sage, pass mal auf, ihr habt da folgendes Problem in dieser Software mit Hilfe oder unter Ausnutzung dieses Problemes, kann ich äh
jemand anderem Schaden zufügen oder Informationen an Informationen gelangen,
Ähm und üblicherweise macht man das dann so, dass man irgendwie den den Betroffenen äh Software äh Bude oder äh,
der Gruppe, die diese Software Menthen Bescheid sagt und dann eine eine Zeit in
in ins Land ziehen lässt, die also es dem der Bevölkerung ermöglicht und den Nutzern ermöglicht, das Update äh zu bekommen, um sich vor dieser Sicherheitslücke zu schützen,
Und dann, sagen wir mal, auf irgendeiner Konferenz, zum Beispiel äh CCC-Kongress oder irgendeine andere IT-Sicherheitskonferenz, dann äh damit angeben zu können, dass man diese Lücke gefunden hat und wie sie genau äh
äh äh funktioniert hat, ja, dass man dann auch noch so die die Würdigung äh der der Community äh für seine Arbeit an der Stelle bekommt.
Der lautere Umgang mit dieser äh Sache. Das Problem ist, dass natürlich damit sich nur sehr, sehr äh mittelbar Geld verdienen lässt, nämlich dann höchstens dadurch, dass man irgendwelche Aufträge bekommt für Security-Reviews. Ähm,
eine Möglichkeit, diese Sicherheitslücke sehr viel lukrativer äh in unmittelbar in Geld zu verwandeln, ist natürlich sie an einen Unterhändler oder direkt an einen Geheimdienst zu verkaufen oder an Kriminelle.
Die ein äh Geschäftsmodell oder sonstiges äh politisches Interesse an mit dieser Sicherheitslücke verfolgen können. Und äh einer der entscheidenden
Akteure auf diesem Schwarzmarkt oder
sind natürlich die internationalen Geheimdienste, die Interesse haben, solche äh Sicherheitslücken zu kaufen,
und ähm das heißt, der Schwarzmarkt für äh gleich mal unmoralische IT-Sicherheitsforschung wird,
zu einem großen Teil äh durch das Budget der Geheimdienste unterhalten. Nicht nur der NSA,
aber eben äh im im besonderen Rahmen.
Von welchen ähm Geheimdiensten meint man denn noch zu wissen, dass sie in diesem Bereich unterwegs sind oder meint man zu wissen, dass alle da mittlerweile unterwegs sind?
Da habe ich äh also da habe ich keinen genauen Überblick, welcher Geheimdienst da offiziell ähm Budgets für hat und welcher nicht die Budgets der Geheimdienste sind ja ohnehin. Ähm,
sehr äh grob, nur äh zugänglich und da steht ja jetzt nicht nachher im Rechenschaftsbericht irgendwie äh Zero Days äh für fünf Millionen gejobbt.
Also deswegen weiß ich nicht. Ähm bei der NSA durch diesen Entschluss jetzt,
des US-Repräsentantenhauses oder das war natürlich auch offenkundig, dass die NSA ihr Wissen nicht äh ausschließlich ähm selber,
generiert, ne.
Die Haushaltsverhandlungen im Bundestag waren ja auch gerade oder finden gerade statt. Und die Beratung,
wurden aber, also die Beratung zum Geheimdienstetat, die wurden schon im Vorfeld,
abgesprochen. Da gibt's einen interessanten Rat, wie heißt der nochmal gleich? Vertrauensrat oder Verantwortungsrat.
Keine Ahnung.
Nicht der Ältestenrat. Ich komme gerade nicht drauf,
wo das dann sozusagen schon mal so besprochen wird. So und wenn das durch ist, dann darf bitte das debattiert werden.
Der V-Männerrat,
Mir fällt äh um das noch kurz hier in den USA zu ähm zu Ende zu bringen. Also in USA gibt es den Congress und in dem gibt's zwei Kammern,
Einmal das äh House of Representivs und einmal den Sanit und dieser Beschluss, den ich jetzt grade äh äh angesprochen habe, der sich gegen die äh,
Möglichkeit der NSA wendet Sicherheitslücken zu kaufen,
hat also das House of Representivs passiert, müsste jetzt noch durch den,
Wobei unklar ist, was der äh Sammet dazu sagen wird und dann, weil es ein reines, ein, ein normales Gesetz ist, müsste das dann auch noch über den äh Schreibtisch von Barack Obama. Ja, das heißt also, da sind noch zwei Hürden ähm,
Und mit Barack Obama sicherlich eine äh größere Hürde, ähm damit das auch tatsächlich gesetzt wird. Und man kann dann natürlich noch länger darüber philosophieren ähm in welcher Form,
dieses Gesetz dann auch tatsächlich,
umgesetzt würde, ja? Oder ob nicht die schwarzen Kassen der NSA ausreichend,
groß sind, um das einfach aus einem anderen Topf zu bezahlen.
Also kommt jetzt auch darauf an, wie dann dieses Gesetz in seiner finalen Form äh formuliert ist.
Aber weil wir ja immer sagen, es tut sich nix, ne? Da hat sich jetzt irgendwie mal grade ein bisschen was getan. Da hat jemand in den USA ein zaghaften Versuch unternommen und konnte eine Mehrheit für etwas gewinnen, was eventuell irgendwas ändern könnte.
Es gibt schon so eine gewisse äh Beunruhigung. Ich meine, äh die USA steht ja nun auch einfach ganz anders in der internationalen Debatte da, als zum Beispiel äh Deutschland, ja. Also erstmal zeigt keiner auf Deutschland,
Deutschland so beschäftigt damit ist auf alle anderen zu zeigen ja? Und irgendwie die sowieso nicht so richtig ernst genommen werden was sie wahrscheinlich auch richtig stört,
Ja, bei den USA ist irgendwie klar, dass sie jetzt so wie die Bad Guys sind. So, also zumindest in der in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung. Das ist ja nun wirklich nicht zu leugnen und,
Das stört die natürlich, also es stört nicht alle, aber es stört auf jeden Fall manche,
Weil sie einfach auch so ein Selbstbild haben. Also ich denke jetzt nicht, dass jeder Abgeordneter irgendwie
in den USA Repräsentantenhaus total cool damit ist das irgendwie die USA einen schlechten Ruf haben, weil sie sich ja nun selber auch ganz anders sehen und äh vielleicht teilweise auch zurecht,
ja und einfach mit diesem Image gar nicht leben wollen und jetzt durchaus da Bedarf sehen das zu ändern, also vielleicht auch aus inhaltlichen Gründen und nicht nur aus Image,
aber äh letztlich soll's mir egal sein, was äh hier zu einem Bewusstseinswandel äh führt, nur,
weitreichend wird es nicht sein und wie du schon sagtest, hier gibt es noch zwei, drei äh Vetooptionen durch andere Kammern, den,
Also durch die andere Kammer und eben durch den Präsiden da ist noch überhaupt nichts durch.
Überhaupt nichts durch und wir erinnern uns an, welch meine Obama hat ja schon vor ein paar oder war das Obama, der es gesagt hat, werden das auf jeden Fall in Logbuch Netzpolitik auch behandelt, wo sie sagten,
sicher wissen über Sicherheitslücken
gehen wir sofort weiter. Die NSA äh verhindert doch nicht irgendwie, dass die, dass die äh Computer der Bürger äh unsicher äh sicherer werden. Es sei denn, die Sicherheitslücken eignen sich zur Bekämpfung von Terrorismus. Das war ja auch so, oder natürlich eignet sich jede Sicherheitslücke theoretisch auch
in irgendeiner Form an den Haaren herbeiziehbar zur Bekämpfung des Terrorismus. Kann man bei jeder einzelnen Sicherheitslücke ähm,
Relativ schön an den Haaren irgendwie herbeiziehen.
Terror geht immer.
So und dann äh sollte aber der CCC mal äh ordentlich ran und mal äh einen Brückenschlag äh mit,
durchführen, ja, die finale Versöhnung, die äh endlich also mal auch die ganze internationale Debatte. All das, was,
durch vormalige Regierungen und sonstige Ereignisse zerschlagen worden ist. All dieses Porzellan,
geklebt werden, indem ein Cyber Dialog äh in Wallung gesetzt wird. Wo soll dieser Cyber-Dialog stattfinden oder fand der schon statt?
Äh der findet, glaube ich, jetzt im Moment ein, der hat Anfang dieser Woche stattgefunden und soll dann jetzt morgen oder so in äh also soll dann auch die,
Vertreter von äh zivilgesellschaftlichen und wirtschaftlichen Interessengruppen dann sich da äußern können.
Und da steht natürlich der CCC in der ersten äh Reihe Reihe und äh sorgt für die finale Versöhnung.
Ja, um jetzt mal kurz zu erklären, was dieser Cyber-Dialog ist. Der Cyberdialog ist das, was übrig geblieben ist, von,
Fragenkatalog, den die Bundesregierung an die USA geschickt hat.
Den sie nicht beantwortet haben.
Der nicht beantwortet wurde und dem groß angekündigten No-Spy-Abkommen. Also.
Was auch keiner wollte.
Bayern-Abkommen, ich habe das heute Morgen, glaube ich, so bezeichnet, das wurde schon vor der Terminvereinbarung für die Planungsphase abgesagt, ja? Da ist war ja einfach nur so ein Wort, äh was wo alle sagte, oh ja, jetzt hier ein Abkommen,
und äh eine Woche.
Amerikaner haben gesagt ja nee geht gar nicht.
Kit gewinnt nicht.
Notarzt. Ja und äh das ist also das, was jetzt ein Jahr später äh übrig geblieben ist, ja? Ähm,
Man fragt sich jetzt, also in der gleichen Woche, ja, in der wir erfahren, die arbeiten schon seit zehn Jahren zusammen,
mindestens seit zehn Jahren und zwar in einer, in einer,
Art und Weise, die jede Form von äh Demokratie oder Rechtsstaaten schon längst hinter sich gelassen hat. Ja, das sind Kumpels seit über zehn Jahren. Ausgerechnet der Steinweiher, deswegen spare ich das ja gerade an.
Der damals schon verantwortlich zeitet, setzt sich zehn Jahre später, setzt er sich hin mit irgendwelchen äh,
US-Fuzzies aus der dritten, vierten Reihe und machte einen auf Cyber-Dialog und lädt hundert.
Also es geht jetzt auch noch vom äh Außenministerium aus.
Selbstverständlich. Ja, Frank-Walter Steinmeier lädt ein zum Cyber-Dialog
und ähm da sollen dann also irgendwie hundert Interessengruppen hin und irgendwie ein Amerikaner oder so und dann kann jeder mal sagen, das finden wir nicht gut und dann werden wird jeder seine Rede halten von ähm,
äh Terror.
Irgendwas mit Datenschutz.
Terror, irgendwas mit Datenschutz und gesundes Mittelmaß und Schutz und Sicherheit, ja? Und äh dann können wir alle wieder nach Hause gehen.
Eine gemeinsame Zukunft.
Für eine gemeinsame Zukunft äh ne und digitaler Wandel Menschenhand und so, ne?
Das muss auch mal gesagt werden.
Das muss auch mal ganz gesagt werden.
Betone das auch noch einmal.
Und jeder weiß, dass äh es natürlich eigentlich nur um Terroristen geht. Also so eine Veranstaltung ist da äh ist da äh findet da jetzt gerade statt. Und wie gesagt, erst, ne, vor.
Warum fällt mir da gerade wieder Loriot ein?
Ne und aber,
Und ich wurde dann heute Morgen ähm im Deutschlandradio äh sollte ich erklären, warum denn der CCC da nicht wenigstens hingeht
und äh meine Antwort war, ja, der CCC geht heute lieber in den NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss, ähm als äh Sachverständiger ist Frank Rieger heute da
Wie gesagt, und ähm ich denke, wir arbeiten mal lieber darauf hin, dass jetzt ein äh Licht auf die Zusammenarbeit zwischen,
BNT,
Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und NSA geleuchtet wird, um erstmal im eigenen Lande dann da zu kehren, statt uns da jetzt irgendwie zu Sockenpuppen zu machen in so einer Alibi-Veranstaltung, wo ja selbst Steinmeier sagt, da wird nichts bei rumkommen.
Erklärte mir heute der D-Radiomoderator. Ich habe das Zitat äh so nicht gefunden. Aber das ist wirklich eine äh äh,
Obama sagte ja, ja, ja, dieser Dialog, der wird super, weil wir dir logisieren da, um dann die wenigen noch bestehenden Meinungsunterschiede über unsere Ziele und Absichten zu verringern.
Ja
Also er sagt dann tatsächlich so, wir wir erklären euch das mal, wir erklären euch unsere Absichten nochmal, Terror, Terror, Terror.
Mhm.
Verhindern, also der ne schon. Und dann werdet ihr das besser verstehen, warum wir uns weigern,
Abkommen mit euch zu unterzeichnen,
unten. Der eigentliche Hintergrund, ähm dass eben diese jahrelange oder offensichtliche Jahrzehnte lange Kooperation besteht, der wird dann mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit eher nicht beleuchtet werden, ne.
Tja.
Und ich frage mich auch, warum wird da überhaupt, warum wird da die ähm,
Zivilgesellschaft eingeladen, wenn sie gleichzeitig, ja, über die letzten zehn Jahre.
Im Dunkeln gehalten wurde, ja?
Also wenn nicht in dieser Woche äh süddeutsche und NDR oder was diese Sache mit dem Dezix rausgepuhlt und veröffentlicht hätten, dann hätte dieser Cyber-Dialog ohne dieses Wissen stattgefunden. Was ist das denn für eine Veranstaltung?
Ja, aber wir konnten doch niemanden davon äh erzählen, weil das war doch geheim.
Ja eben, der kein Dialog zu machen. Hier wir machen ganz wir wir sagen dir nicht worüber wir reden.
Ja äh hört euch mal äh Linus Statement äh an, da im Deutschlandfunk,
hat schon ganz gut getroffen. Ähm für meinen Geschmack hättest du noch durchaus mehr in die Kerbe hauen können wie,
sinnlos eigentlich solche, was für Berührungsveranstaltungen das auch sind, solche, solche Events.
Also ich wurde am Ende zitiert mit äh da wird unsere Energie verballert. Ich glaube viel, viel krasser hätte ich's nicht mehr ausdrücken können. Ich muss auch immer sagen, wie gesagt, die diese Interviews sind irgendwie sehr früh morgens und das ist ähm,
teilweise schwierig da äh nicht noch während des Interviews irgendwie wieder einzuschlafen. Äh sechs Uhr fünfzig war das heute wieder.
Äh das ist halt echt Hardcore. Aber wichtiger Punkt hier für die Aktivisten von morgen, wenn ihr was bewegen wollt, früh aufstehen.
Ja, wer was äh bewegen will, früh aufstehen und äh in die Untersuchungsausschüsse gehen, mein ähm der der Untersuchungsausschuss ist natürlich ähm.
Auch so eine Veranstaltung.
Hat eine ähnlich ähm,
ähnlich wenig Wegweisende na, wie soll man sagen, hat ähnlich geringen Ausblick darauf, irgendetwas äh an dem an dem Status quo zu ändern, aber immerhin hat man da.
Eine deutlich höhere Medienaufmerksamkeit als das A Untersuchungsausschüsse an sich schon mal haben, wenigen Ausnahmen,
normale politische Prozesse, in dem so ein Statement äh generell verpuffen würde. Untersuchungsausschuss hat immer noch so ein bisschen so dieses äh Smoking Gunn äh
Vielleicht findet man ja doch äh was bei Geschmack und.
Ja und du hast vor allem nachher eine Stellungnahme, die als Bundestagsdrucksache äh
letztendlich in in die in die Archive der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik eingeht, ja? Letzt, also da wird man sich dann, da kann man sich dann drauf berufen, ja? Ähm
wenn man einhundert äh Vertreter von irgendwelchen Interessengruppen einlädt, kann man sich leicht ausrechnen, wie viele,
Redezeit da jedem einzelnen zur Verfügung steht. Also es hat totale ähm,
totale äh totales Ablenkungsmanöver, um da äh Kapazitäten zu binden. Hm, kann ich auch mit gutem Gewissen sagen, da gehen wir nicht hin.
Linus, dann sind wir, glaube ich, am Ende äh angekommen. Wie ist der Ausblick? Veranstaltungen, gerade keine äh in Sicht, ne?
Wüsste jetzt zumindest nix, aber irgendwas wird sich schon wieder aufdrehen,
Nächste Ausgabe werden wir dann mal ein kleines Special äh wieder haben. So viel sei schon mal angekündigt.
Und ja, ansonsten, wir freuen uns nach wie vor über eure äh klugen Kommentare.
Auch auf Facebook übrigens. Hast du gesehen? Äh,
Hier Facebook haben wir haben wir Kommentare.
Oh, ja.
Da waren, nee, Tim, jetzt mal ganz ehrlich, da äh ich war äh.
Was?
Überrascht. Also es gibt Facebook dot com. Oh, was haben die uns gelöscht? Ach so.
Nämlich so schnell nicht.
Also Likes und so hier ne noch und nöcher. Und ähm Kommentare,
Zum Beispiel hat äh,
äh Alexander Kenngott dessen äh Existenz als reale Person, wie er in der letzten Folge noch angezweifelt haben, hier festgestellt, dass er existiert äh und siebzehn Kommentare oder was hier.
Das ist schon äh das ist schon ordentlich und die sind äh von der Qualität her jetzt nicht zu unterscheiden von denen, die wir äh selbst hosten, außer dass.
Sich nicht sicher sein kann, dass man überhaupt alle äh kriegt.
Ja, also.
Naja, ist ja so.
Ja, ich will, es ist nahe, Facebook halt, ne. Also ich hab's auch bis heute noch nicht ganz verstanden, wie ich jetzt, also ich könnte jetzt wohl antworten, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das.
Wie kriegt man das per RSS, wie kriegt man das per Mail?
Gibt's nicht.
Na ja, ist doch alles Dreck.
Facebook ist, also darüber sind wir uns einig. Ich wollte nur jetzt mal auch hier eine Lanze für für die armen Seelen bei Facebook brechen, dass sie da jetzt also sie haben geantwortet und das ist äh in Ordnung. Das ist.
Auf jeden Fall zu begrüßen. Ich will mich jetzt da auch nicht gegen die Leute stellen. Ich will nur muckelig und äh muckelig sein und ein alter Mann spielen.
Ja ähm.
Du weißt, das ist eine Technologie, die zu einem Zeitpunkt meines Lebens äh dazugekommen ist.
Wo du über dreißig warst.
Alles schon äh vom Bösen ist, ne.
Facebook ist ohne Zweifel böse und deswegen will ich ja genau in den in dir bös, im Kern des Bösen unsere Saat, unsere Saat unterbringen, weißt du? Ich möchte, dass Facebook die die.
Räumen. Wir sprengen, das System von innen.
Genau, wir unterwandern ist der lange Marsch durch die äh,
durch die Monopole oder.
Durch die digitalen Institutionen, die er oh Mann. Na gut, viel Spaß ähm dabei. Äh wir bleiben skeptisch und ihr bleibt das auch. Und äh insofern sagen wir tschüss,
tschüss.
Meine Damen und Herren, was kann als Grundsatz parlamentarische Arbeit betrachtet werden?
Politik im Sinne sozialer Verantwortung bedeutet und davon sollte man ausgehen, das ist doch unsere Situation, in der wir uns,
finde. Ich kann den Standpunkt meiner politischen Überzeugung in wenige Worte zusammenfassen. Erstens, das Selbstverständnis unter der Voraussetzung,
Zweitens, und das ist es, was wir unseren Wählern schuldig sind. Drittens, die konzentrierte Beinhaltung,
eine zukunftweisenden Parteiprogramms. Wer hat denn und das sollte man vor diesem hohen Hause einmal unmissverständlich,
auch die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung hatte sich in jeder Weise, das kann von niemandem bestritten werden, ohne zu verkennen, dass in Brüssel, in London, die Ansicht herrscht, die,
DP-Koalition habe da und meine Damen und Herren, warum auch nicht. Und wo haben wir denn letzten Endes ohne die Lage unnötig,
da meine Genossen und meine Damen und Herren.
Denken Sie doch einmal an die Bildungspolitik. Wer war es denn, der seit fünfzehn Jahren und wir wollen einmal davon absehen, dass niemand behaupten kann, als hätte sich damals, so geht.
Ich habe immer wieder darauf hingewiesen, dass die Fragen des Umweltschutzes und ich bleibe dabei, wo kämen wir sonst hin? Wo bliebe unsere Glaubwürdigkeit? Eins steht doch fest. Und darüber gibt es keinen Zweifel.
Nicht verstanden.
Politik geht von der Voraussetzung aus, dass die mittelfristige Finanzplanung und im Bereich der Steuerreform ist das schon immer von ausschlaggebender Bedeutung gewesen,
Meine meine Damen und Herren, soziale Gerechtigkeit,
Verpflichtung, wir wollen nicht vergessen, draußen im Lande hier und heute stellen sich die Fragen und damit möchte ich schließen. Letzten Endes, der muss das bestreiten. Ich danke Ihnen.